[Music]
hey you guys so you knew that i wasn't
gonna let the halloween season pass
without doing a little something extra
uh if you're a long time viewer of the
show like one of our regulars uh you
know that initially my plan
which turned out to be uh way too much
for me to handle was i was gonna do a 31
days of horror so i was going to do like
31 extra reviews like one for every day
of october well as most of you know uh
we ended up having to move sort of
unexpectedly or more quickly than we had
anticipated so i didn't really have time
to do that but i still wanted to do
something special for halloween so i
just decided to do
just a week
of extra reviews just one you know
review every day leading up to halloween
so there'll at least be something to
commemorate the best holiday of the year
and because i'm a dork i called it eek
week because of course i did so
that's what we're gonna do this week
we're doing seven extra movie reviews of
movies that
i had been wanting to get around to for
like a really long time and just hadn't
got to it and i also kind of wanted to
they're not all
specifically halloween based but i did
definitely want to
i don't know i did definitely want to
concentrate on films that gave me that
kind of halloweeny sort of vibe some of
them are very halloween you know based
but i kind of liked you know like a
witchy
old school ghost story type of thing and
i wanted that kind of vibe like with all
the movies that i was gonna do so uh i'm
not gonna spoil which ones are gonna
turn up but you know maybe you'll see if
you're on patreon maybe you'll see i
might i might put the list up there so
you can see so uh i got my little witchy
poo my little friend here and uh she's
going to talk about have little
different friends
depending on what movie i'm talking
about so uh today we are talking about
black sunday which is kind of a witch
movie um you know we'll get into that a
little bit but so i decided to put one
of my little witch buddies here to just
kind of
sit in place over there and listen to me
talking about this movie
so black sunday this came out in 1960
and can i just say 1960
was a hell of a year for
modern horror as far as influential
films coming out um obviously in the
united states 1960 we saw the release of
psycho uh and in the uk we had the
release of peeping tom so there's
definitely something in
the culture at large western culture at
large that horror movies were
kind of coming out the gate being more
violent you know what i mean so even
though black sunday
is almost kind of like a throwback to
the more gothic uh universal films of
the 30s and 40s it did have like a much
much more violent
you know like a lot more gore and stuff
like that whereas you know psycho and
peeping tom were kind of more like
getting away from the gothic tradition
and just going in a more like straight
up serial killer violent sort of
direction and both of those things
almost kind of like coalesced uh into
one sort of thing like i said all three
of those films coming out the same year
and actually almost around the same time
because if i'm not mistaken uh they all
came out within about a month of each
other uh if i'm remembering correctly i
wasn't alive back then but you know i
did read about it so they but they all
came out like right around the same time
and were all
fairly controversial depending on the
country that they were uh released in
so what ends up happening with black
sunday which is actually not uh the name
that it was originally released under
because it actually didn't get released
in the u.s until 1961 and we'll get into
that in a little bit but it was
initially released in italy as la
mascara del demonio or the mask of the
demon
you know later known as the mask of
satan
and it was basically mario bava
the legendary italian film director who
probably i mean easily more than anyone
else very very uh influential in italian
cinema and uh particularly
influential in the giallo uh genre the
horror genre big influence on dario
argento
so we'll get into that a little bit too
but
he had been a cinematographer uh prior
to this
and uh if you've seen any of his films
that will become readily apparent
because his films are actually really
really beautiful looking uh so he knows
how to how to frame a shot and how to
make everything look fantastic he had
actually worked on some uh sword and
sandal films from back coming out of
italy uh among them hercules and
hercules unchained both of which i
believe were i think they both turned up
on mystery science theater now that i'm
thinking about it not bad movies by any
stretch of the imagination but you know
so there's that whole thing so because
he had worked on i think he worked on
kaltiki the immortal monster as well
which you know that didn't do all that
well but the hercules movie is big hit
and they were also like a big hit in the
united states too like when they got uh
imported over here so mario bava
was given uh they're like basically okay
well you know now you can direct your
own movie so let's see what you come out
with
now he decided uh between him and the
producers and whoever they decided they
were going to do a horror film because
hammer had recently released dracula in
1958 which was directed by terence
fisher and it was like really really
successful so they figured okay well
horror is going to be the way to go
now what mario bava initially wanted to
do
was he had written a screen treatment uh
i believe the first draft was only like
four pages
where
he wanted to make a movie based on the
russian short story by nikolai gogul
called
vv
voi
i don't really speak questions i'm not
entirely sure i pronounce it like i
listened to like the pronunciation thing
but i was like trying to do it and i'm
just like i can't get it exactly right
but yeah so it's basically a story about
like a bunch of students and they
encounter this
witch uh who in like a it's kind of like
a gnome type of thing
so he wrote a story and he said that he
really really liked that story
and he had uh read it to his kids like
when they were growing up and everything
so he really wanted to make a film
adaptation of that so he wrote like a
screen treatment took it to the
producers and they're like yeah we
didn't really like that um so
they had all these other screenwriters
come in and sort of uh rewrite it so
even though uh i think by believe the
credits do say that it's based on that
short story
um it really doesn't retain
all that much of the story um basically
yeah there's a witch in it and yeah
there's like an old crumbling crypt in
it and there's the whole thing where the
witch appears like as a young beautiful
woman
but that's pretty much the extent of the
similarity
i will say that there was actually a
pretty faithful adaptation of it made uh
in the soviet union in 1967
which if you want to see it i think it's
on shutter actually i haven't watched it
yet but um it's kind of like a classic i
think it's in their essential horror
section
uh because it's kind of like a really
influential film from then but so there
have been like several movie adaptations
of this short story and even though uh
black sunday is listed as it um it's not
it really hardly doesn't have anything
to do with it they did kind of use a lot
of the names and it's set in the same
area like it's set in moldavia so it has
like a russian
flavor to it
or an eastern european type of flavor to
it but other than other than it being
kind of about a witch it's not really
all that similar so the movie comes out
in italy and it does okay but not great
now
american international pictures um who
had been having as i mentioned a lot of
success with italian import films like
the sword and sandal films and stuff uh
we're basically oh that sounds pretty
good we'll release it over here
and
they decided i think there's a version
of it that's called the mask of satan
but for whatever reason um they decided
they were gonna call it black sunday i
don't know if it was to tie in with
black sabbath uh the anthology film that
had boris karloff in it although i think
that came out later um but i don't know
so they decided to retitle it black
sunday they actually redubbed it uh and
they added a new score because they
thought the original score was quote
unquote two italian which i'm not
entirely sure what that means but okay
and uh so yeah and also they cut out
four minutes of
gore
because this for 1960
this is a pretty
uh gory movie and like the special
effects are pretty i mean obviously by
today's standards you know it's nothing
but
i mean compared to like the freak out
people had about psycho which
was violent but a lot of the violence
was implied
and same with peeping tom
uh which i would argue is a little bit
more violent but that was also like
implied
this one not imply
it's like it's pretty gruesome and it
just goes for it and shows
everything that it's gonna show because
you know italy that's kind of their
thing so uh they weren't implying [ __ ]
they were just kind of like there it is
so for 1960 this was a very very violent
gory film so like i said when they
released it in the united states um they
cut four minutes out of it so there are
a few versions of this floating around i
believe that the most common version
nowadays which is just called black
sunday even though the title card when
you watch the film says the mask of
satan on it
has um it has an english dub and i'm not
really sure which score it has but i'm
pretty sure that all of this stuff has
been restored at this point because i
think it's back to like 87 minutes so it
so if you're watching it like because
it's on shutter it's on like a bunch of
other streaming services if you're
watching out there i'm 99 sure that this
is you know the original version it's
not like the cut up aip version so when
they released it in the united states it
was about you know i don't even know if
it was an entire year later but it came
out a little while afterward and it was
usually um kind of they they showed it
like on double features they usually
showed it with like little shop of
horrors the roger corman film uh and it
was actually really really successful
actually in
the us and in other parts of uh you know
in like france and stuff like that it
was actually a lot more successful than
it was in italy and it got like a better
critical response it seemed like in
italy uh critics didn't really like it
all that much and like i said it did
okay but it didn't do all that great
like money-wise um but france and the
united states were kind of like the the
critics you know reviews were mixed but
they were actually a lot better and i
think a lot of that
comes from
i mean this is if you're into like
gothic
horror films especially if you like like
the classics like like the universal
monster movies and stuff like that this
is a beautiful beautiful movie it's just
like every single frame of it
just looks like
a gothic wet dream it's just it's
fantastic it's just the sets are
beautiful the costumes are beautiful
just the framing is beautiful just the
way it's done at the
the camera movements it has these kind
of like fluid camera movements some of
which were actually very influential on
some later horror films which i'll
probably bring up in a bit
but it's just i mean obviously you can
see like a lot of the influence of this
and you can tell yes it's a it's a very
gothic film um but like i said i and i
guess this was something that was going
on the time because hammer was kind of
doing this too where they were taking
like gothic movies and then like bumping
up the boobs and the gore and that's
kind of what this one is doing too
there's really there's not any nudity in
this one other than
uh a nude there's a nude painting
of barbara steele's character at one
point but i don't think she actually
gets naked in it there's like cleavage a
lot of heaving booby cleavage and stuff
but i don't think there's any nudity but
uh as far as gore goes this was like
pretty off the charts for 1860. and uh
you can definitely tell that this was
a big big influence on uh italian
filmmaking and american filmmaking in
general too uh and i was going to say
too that tim burton actually um
this was one of his favorite films from
childhood and made like a huge
impression on him and he also did an
homage to it in his movie sleepy hollow
and i've also seen like a couple of um
reviewers say that maybe francis ford
coppola's dracula which came out in the
early 90s uh that there's one shot in
that like the one shot where dracula's
um shadow is coming through like
knocking [ __ ] over and everything like
that um that could be an homage to a
scene in black sunday because there is a
scene like that like very similar to
that uh in black sunday as well
so what we have going on in this movie
uh barbara steele now she had been in
movies prior to this but she was still
kind of you know this was kind of like
early in her career
uh the story goes i guess she had been
working in hollywood but there was a
strike and so a lot of american actors
went over to italy like to get some work
uh the story goes that mario baba just
saw a picture of her
either in life magazine or had seen her
headshot or something like that and was
like yeah i want her for my movie
because her face looks [ __ ] great uh
so kind of got her over there now again
legend goes that she was very very
difficult to work with uh she kind of
apologized for that later saying you
know i was really young i was really
inexperienced i never worked in italy
before i didn't really speak italian uh
there was a lot of misunderstandings uh
i also heard
that
she didn't like she only got the script
pages for what was going on that day of
shooting so she didn't really have much
of an idea of the overarching story
which i think there's a couple times in
the movie where you can kind of see that
but it's like i'm not really sure it's
it's hard to say if it was like
deliberate or whatever but i mean she
was for real and i love barbara steele
like this and this movie
made her even though the movie didn't do
all that well in italy it made her like
an instant movie star in italy and then
obviously she went on to be in like a
[ __ ] ton of other horror films and other
films as well but yeah she went on to
work with david cronenberg and
you know and everything so
uh so she actually
you know she said she was difficult on
the set and like i said she kind of
apologized for it and some of the other
people working on like on the crew and
everything were like yeah she was like
really weird and like neurotic and she
had kind of like paranoid fantasies
about like other people working on the
film that they were like out to get or
something like that but uh yeah so it
was a big thing but the movie came out
good so you know so it's fine the
opening scene of this movie i would
argue
is
easily if not the best one of the best
opening scenes in classic horror because
and honestly in the first the opening
scene is so good that it's almost like
the rest of the movie can't quite live
up to it just because it just opens with
such a bang
basically you have barbara steele
playing this witch named asa
and she's kind of tied to a stake or
whatever and her brother is there
talking about her and her um
her kind of sidekick lover you know a
partner in crime whatever
uh and they're kind of they're going to
execute both of them and they're going
to burn them at the stake and whatever
and you know and of course she being a
witch
basically is like yeah curse all you
[ __ ] and you know you're i'm
gonna curse your entire family line like
for hundreds of years and everything
like that and then so the brother comes
out and they take this mask it's
essentially like an eye like the face of
an iron maiden but it's just the mask
part and it kind of looks like the devil
on the outside like it's all kind of
[ __ ] up but all the inside is like all
spikes
so there's this great shot where they
show kind of like the outside of the
of the mask and then it kind of like uh
then he films through the eyes and you
can see her like kind of freaking out
like oh [ __ ] and then they kind of like
turn it around and there's like this
great shadow like on all the spikes and
everything and then they legit put the
mask onto her face
and this dude like it executioner's head
has this massive like wooden mallet and
he goes whack and he just like [ __ ]
nails the [ __ ] right to her face and
blood comes out the [ __ ] top and
blood comes out the eye holes it's
[ __ ] i mean it's black and white but
it's [ __ ] great and so you can see
why 1960 uh something like this would
have been extremely shocking
because
most other movies like i said would have
cut away and maybe just suggested that
with a sound effect or whatever but this
one absolutely did not uh it actually
just shows the mass just going whack
like onto the face and the blood
shooting out and everything like that
it's [ __ ] great so like i said that's
a it's just a great [ __ ] opening
sequence like with this witch or
whatever
so then we jump ahead uh 200 years i
think it's 200 years
so we have these two like a doctor and
his like younger doctor companion right
you got dr kruvijan who's the older guy
and his assistant who's dr gorobek or
andre as he's called they're going
through moldavia in their carriage and
they're on their way to this uh you know
this uh medical conference i guess
they're going to
so obviously this being a horror movie
uh the the wheel falls off their
carriage uh there's kind of creepy [ __ ]
going on in the woods like their
carriage driver is like man i don't want
to go this way it's a shortcut it's like
the trees are coming to get me and all
this other kind of stuff so there's all
this foreshadowing and so yeah so the
carriage uh kind of breaks down so the
driver has to fix it now while the
driver is going to fix it the two
doctors decide hey well let's they hear
this weird noise so they kind of go off
into the woods to
to find out what it is because that's
just something that you do in horror
movies which you should never do in real
life i hear a weird noise like out in
the middle of the dark woods at night
i'd be like yeah i'm just gonna stay
right here and not even i'm not even
curious about what that is because i'm
sure it's nothing good but uh so yeah so
they decided to go investigate this
noise and it turns out that the noise is
actually this old pipe organ and there's
like all this wind blowing through the
pipe board and they're like oh well that
explains that but then they notice like
this really run down
crypt and they're like oh
kick ass you know what i mean which is
again that's probably what i would say
and uh that probably would have been the
end of it but then they see like the
door of the crypt like it kind of like
open like kind of opens and closes by
itself they're like huh maybe somebody's
in there or like maybe somebody lives in
there so they decide to go in and check
it out because like i said it's a horror
movie so they go in there and it's like
a crypt like i said there's like tombs
and [ __ ] like that and uh they find the
one tomb which belonged to assa
obviously the witch
and it's great because it's like there's
the coffin and the coffin has like a
window in the top so you can see the her
the mask like her face they left it on
there and then the window is there and
then there's like a cross that's kind of
like you know up on the coffin and the
older doctor explains he's like oh yeah
this is the [ __ ] they used to do back
then the superstition when they uh
executed a witch they figured they'd
keep her in there by so she'd have to
like look at the cross all the time so
she couldn't get out now i will say too
that even though asa
is she's called a witch
but
she's also kind of like a vampire in the
sense that she kind of comes back from
the dead and she like drinks blood like
blood makes her stronger
and she does kind of like vampirey [ __ ]
so
she's kind of a witch and she's kind of
a vampire and then she's also kind of a
satanist
so
there's so it's kind of like confusing
but whatever as they were just kind of
like
whatever like i said the original story
it was a witch
with a gnome sidekick that had an iron
face which i guess is where they got the
idea for like the mask of satan from
but
you know like i said so so it's very
witchy but she also has like vampire
aspects to her as well
so there's that whole thing going on
just just roll with it it's italy
they're not super worried about it now
the funny thing about this is so like
the older doctor is just kind of like
yeah well you know she you know she
can't get out of the coffin or that was
what they believed like obviously
because he's a doctor and he's like i
don't believe in these silly
superstitions but he's like they they
believed that when they put her in the
ground like if they didn't put that
cross there for her to look at then
she'd like pop back out and [ __ ] [ __ ] up
so they're like that's what they do now
in a very hilarious and very contrived
scene the younger doctor is like yeah
i'm gonna go check on that carriage and
see when we can get the [ __ ] out of here
doctor's like well okay i'm just gonna
you know fart around in here for a
little while and then he gets attacked
by this massive
bat right
so the bat's like flying around and he
has his cane and he's like beating the
[ __ ] out of this bat and of course while
he's beating the [ __ ] out of the bat he
not only breaks open the window in the
coffin but he also breaks the cross
and i'm just kind of like really but
then i mean i don't know because later
on there's like some dialogue in the
film that maybe leads one to believe
that
that was done like on purpose like
supernaturally like maybe she was
you know engineering it from like inside
the grave like hey let me out like
there's somebody in here so i can
manipulate this bat to go fly on the
dude's face and maybe it'll like help me
get out so maybe it wasn't like his
because it just seems really comical
like when you're watching it because i'm
just like oh really like he breaks the
window and he's like oh [ __ ] but he's
like flailing around and he breaks the
cross and i'm just like okay there you
go duper and then because he's broken
everything open
he figures well why the hell not i'm
also going to pull the mask off of her
face you might as well
now she's already like taken away every
other protection so she takes uh he
takes the mask off her face and the the
face looks actually really good um it's
wax and like the eyeballs are you know
there's no eyes it's it's kind of like a
skull but there's like skin there too
and there's like maggots and [ __ ] all
over it looks fantastic so he's like oh
you know she's remarkably well preserved
except for the eyeballs and all this
other stuff and then again like a
dumbass um he cuts himself because
here's like the fourth thing he cuts
himself on the glass from the broken
glass from the window and the blood like
drips on her so of course you know that
she's gonna like come back from the dead
right now i will say my favorite effect
there's some great effects on this by
the way
my favorite effect in this and it still
gets me like every time i see it either
this was in 1960 and this effect and
it's so simply done but it looks really
really great so like when he bleeds on
her and she starts to sort of like
regenerate
they have this great they had this mask
that looked like basically just like her
but like i said this just with eye
sockets and they have like the eyes like
coming back into the sockets
and sort of glowing and they did that
with poached eggs like they had this
thing like underneath and they had like
these poached eggs like coming up
through this like wax uh you know statue
of her that they had made and it looks
great it looks like really like goopy
and they actually really do look like
creepy [ __ ] eyeballs like coming up
there and almost i guess like the way
they lit it it almost looks like when
the eyes kind of come in they're sort of
milky and then they kind of like glow in
the middle like i said it's probably
like the lighting that they did that and
it just looks so [ __ ] great i love
that effect so much and i just love that
they did that with [ __ ]
poached eggs that [ __ ] cracks me up
so yeah so obviously uh this witch asa
is gonna come back to life now there's
also another
woman katya who is also played by
barbara steele
and she is an ancestor of the witch so
the family it's like her dad and her
brother whose name is constantine i
think and her and they are ancestors of
asa so they have kind of like a portrait
of her i don't actually i don't think
the portrait is of her i think the
portrait was of like another female
because i guess every female descendant
looks like barbara steele
and
maybe cause i think like they i think
they mentioned like a hundred years
before
that the witch had come back a hundred
years before and tried to possess the
other woman i think her name was masha
um so so i guess she comes back every
hundred years to like [ __ ] with [ __ ]
but yeah so it's implied that it
happened before but i guess since the
budget on this wasn't huge they couldn't
really show that in flashbacks so they
just kind of like you know they expose
it
about how it happened
so basically what we so what we have is
this whole entire time the younger
doctor who sees katya like standing at
the crypt and she's like super
creepy and so for a second remember when
i said earlier that barbara steele um or
at least the story that i heard was that
she didn't get the whole script or she
didn't know what was going on in the
whole script and she only got stuff that
was going on the day this one scene
where
um where andre the younger doctor
first sees her like standing by the
crypt and she's got a dog and then she's
got like this black cape and she looks
all gothic and amazing
um you know with her big huge she has
those great eyes i think that was kind
of like what a lot of people like
responded to she's just she was a
beautiful beautiful woman so the first
time that he sees her like standing
outside i thought because you had seen i
mean the doctors didn't see it because
they'd already like [ __ ] off from the
crypt but
you the audience had seen uh asa the
witch like kind of regenerating like in
the tomb right and then like a few like
only the next scene you see katya
standing outside of the tomb so you're
almost kind of led to so i thought that
was asa for a second and she was acting
sort of weird like when the doctors are
first like talking to her um so for a
second i thought that
because i didn't realize that they're
you know i've seen this a couple times
but i forgot forgotten the story that
you know that's it's an ancestor and
like the witch is like trying to like
possess her like suck out her life force
or whatever so
i thought oh well she's back already and
she's just like being all creepy and
everything but that's actually just
katya so nobody knows like asa hasn't
like even woke up yet so she's just
acting like that just to be weird
but uh but the young doctor andre he is
immediately
in love with her i mean you know it's
barbara steele so i understand but um so
basically he's like hanging his head out
the thing in the carriage like because
they're going to like an end because
they're on like i said they're on their
way to a conference and they have to you
know go to this inn before they can go
the next day and he's just like hanging
his head out the door the carriage like
looking back at her like he's like a dog
or something it's like super funny so
basically as the story goes on like i
said there's not really any like super
surprises or anything like that because
it's a pretty common
story uh you have the witch asa who is
trying to she try also trying to like
reanimate her
uh buddy like her partner in crime that
also got executed with her like 200
years ago whose name was
jabootic yabootic whatever his name was
he so he kind of comes back sort of
zombie-like like he crawls out of the
grave or whatever but he can do like
poltergeisty [ __ ] like was because he
comes into the castle like where katya
and her family live and you can't see
him like he's invisible but he's knocked
[ __ ] over like he knocks over like
candlesticks and like his suits of armor
and stuff like that so yeah so he does
poltergeist [ __ ] so
so the two of them are basically kind of
like joining forces now that they're
back from the dead and they're trying to
drain all the life force so they do end
up killing katya's dad
draining the life force and uh basically
what assa wants to do is take over
katya's body because you know it's
easier because they just look exactly
lit because they're both barber steele
so she's just like i'm gonna take over
this and just do my evil on the world or
whatever because she's like i said she's
a witch now interestingly like i said uh
not only does she drink blood
kinda i mean she kind of like
when she kills the one guy because she
kills the older doctor
and i think or she like possesses or
takes them over she kind of like kisses
him and it's almost kind of like so i
don't know if she's like actually
sucking blood out or if she's like or if
she's like a psychic vampire or some
kind like she's kind of sucking out life
force or whatever
but blood did animate her also very
vampiric she can be repelled uh as can
her buddy by a cross so all you have to
do is hold the cross up and or put a
cross on and she's just like nope not
having it so again which vampire
satanist maybe we don't know like which
thing it is it's all three things
basically at the same time so so yeah so
basically so they're fighting
asa trying to keep her from taking over
katya's body because like i said the
young doctor has fallen in love with her
so he's gonna try and rescue her and uh
also they're trying to kill the sidekick
uh yavutic yavuti i think is how you
pronounce his name so they're trying to
do that yavutic also he gets like
[ __ ]
uh impaled through the eye so again like
some of the gore in this i yes it's tame
by today's standards but for 1960 people
must just like [ __ ] a brick when they
saw this it's like holy crap like eye
gougings like [ __ ] spikes in the face
is like [ __ ] there's all kind of like
gory [ __ ] there's also a great scene too
like near the end where katya
is that asa is trying to like play a
trick where she's just like oh no that's
the witch over there i'm katya totally
but then
like they then she kind of like opens
her robe up and her uh her whole chest
is like
nasty looking like ribs and stuff and so
like it looks so cool and just like i
just love
the visuals in this movie just so great
and there's also another really cool
trick that they did near the end of the
film which again was done very simply
and you could really only do this if you
shoot in black and white but they did a
um
they did a scene where barbara steele
she's like laying on the slab or
whatever and then her face goes from
like really like shitty like old looking
like in wrinkly to like really young and
beautiful again and they actually did
that like in camera and they did it by
putting a bunch of wrinkles and like
stuff um like hollowing out our eyes and
stuff with a red grease pencil so then
when you do like red or green lights it
kind of like fades from one thing to the
other because the red light will be like
invisible if you put like red light over
it it'll make the makeup disappear so
that's a really common trick and like i
said obviously you can't do that in
color but they could do that in black
and white i guess initially when they
were first talking about making this
movie um the producers wanted it to be
in technicolor but mario bava i guess he
was already thinking about some of these
effect sequences and he was already
thinking about the cinematography
because like i said this was his first
like big official directorial job prior
to this he'd been a cinematographer so
he was like you know he knew his [ __ ] in
that department and so i think that he
was already thinking of like certain
effect scenes that he wanted to do that
would only be able to be done in black
and white uh among them that aging kind
of thing like i said you can't do that
in color obviously um you know now it
would be a piece of piss uh to do it as
the british say but back then not so
much but i just really love like the the
simple effects and like how effective
they were
you know it just goes to show like you
know your craft and [ __ ] like that like
it's it's just really interesting really
fascinating like what you can do uh if
you know what you're doing you know and
i don't remember if i mentioned this
earlier but one of the things that i
heard about this movie was that the
entire that the sets were built in black
and white and i don't think that that's
necessarily the case because i think
that there were photographs of the set
taken and they were in color but that
might have been because that might have
been because of something that barbara
steele said about oh everybody's
costumes were black and white but a lot
of people were like no they weren't um
that was just like some weird [ __ ] that
she was saying so maybe that's where the
misconception came from because i've
seen like some other reviews of this
where i think they mentioned that all
the sets had been built in black and
white and i don't know if that's and i'm
not entirely sure but i don't think that
that's the case i think the sets were
actually in color they were just lit you
know in a way that would because
obviously you can't light things the
same or whatever when you're shooting a
black and white but yeah so mario baba
definitely wanted to shoot uh this in
black and white so as i said
even though
this didn't do that great in italy at
first like when it first came out it
ended up being massively massively
influential not only on italian horror
but on horror just
in the western world everywhere like
around the globe honestly so between
this
psycho and peeping tom it was almost
kind of like all three of those coming
out like right around the same time was
really kind of like that was like a
banner year i guess because a lot of
modern horror you know the roots of
modern horror sort of came from these
movies and then obviously mario baba
would go on to do blood and black lace
which was kind of like a very early
giallo or at least the one there had
been one before that like called the
girl who knew too much which was kind of
like a hitchcockian black and white
thing but uh blood and black lace
was the one that really established all
the tropes uh of the giallo going
forward uh that particularly dario gento
would pick up on you know the super
saturated colors you know the kind of
like dude with the black gloves the
knives the overly sexualized killings uh
you know that type of thing so that's
kind of what that would do and then
mario baba would go on also to do a bait
the bay of blood uh or
better known as well it's not better
known i just like the title twitch of
the death nerve better that's what it
was released as initially but uh it's
better known as bay of blood uh which
actually that came out in 1970
i want to say and uh very very
influential on the american slasher film
particularly friday the 13th uh the
friday 13th franchise i believe part two
actually
directly ripped off a couple scenes uh
from that including the spear through
the
uh through the two people having sex
which would came right from a bay of
blood mario baba's influence on
cinema uh horror cinema just really
can't be overstated i don't think i mean
because he was just at the forefront of
so much stuff that came along later on
and even though you could argue that
black sunday is kind of like a throwback
because like i said it's very gothic
it's very you know universal monster
type of thing but
you could argue that it's kind of like
the meeting of the past and the future
because it's like yes we have all these
gothic elements i mean you know much in
the same way that hammer uh was doing we
have all these old gothic elements but
we're modernizing it with more nudity
and more gore and uh so that was just
something that was kind of almost like a
natural progression so he was like right
at the forefront of that but yeah so
i feel like if you're a horror fan uh
you really really need to see black
sunday because it's one of those just
like psycho just like peeping tom just
like anything that came out around this
time period it's one of those movies
that was so
influential
that you really owe it to yourself to
kind of see it to see the roots of
modern horror really and even though as
i said by today's standards it's not
that gory at all and it's you know it
it's it's a very gothic movie and it's
not super narratively strong um and even
you could argue that maybe some of the
acting is a little wooden the dubbing is
not that great but that kind of happens
with a lot of italian films so what are
you gonna do
but
visually i mean visually it's just
gorgeous it's a beautiful masterpiece
it's just like every single shot and
just the way it's shot is just fantastic
so definitely check out black sunday and
if you noticed uh because this is this
i'm putting this up on the sunday before
halloween so you knew that i had to do
black sunday for this day because i've
been wanting to do it for a long time
and i was just like well obviously i
have to do it for this day too but yeah
so
this is the first day of my halloween
eek week specials so we're gonna do some
more movies this week leading up to the
day of halloween next sunday so please
look out for all of my videos this week
my extra ones and i will see you guys on
the next one bye
[Music]
you